derrière on avait des gens nous sommes à
saint georges de clarenceville à l'école
le petit clocher il est tôt et les
bénévoles ont déjà les deux mains dans
les bigots vous arrivez à quelle heure
le matin à césar cran tous les matins
tous les mardis et quelqu'un pourquoi
vous faites ça mais pour les enfants xav
bas c'était pour qu'elle nous renvoie
poliment et la religion peut manger
en 2017-2018 statistique canada disait
que 1,2 million d'enfants au canada
vivait de l'insécurité alimentaire est
ce qu'avec la pandémie on peut imaginer
trois ans plus tard presque quatre ans
que ça augmente et on le voit dans nos
programmes de petits déjeuners
assurément on a eu de 5 à 100 % de plus
d'enfants que donc les programmes ont
été adaptés à la réalité de la pandémie
et ça c'est amalgames et également avec
le coût des aliments préemballés qu'on a
dû acheter pour assurer une sécurité
pendant la pandémie et avec l'inflation
des coûts des aliments temps quand on
comprend que les besoins sont grands
pour plusieurs raisons mais entre autres
parce que plus d'enfants librement
le gouvernement fédéral a d'ailleurs
versé 25 millions de dollars en fonds
d'urgence au club des petits déjeuners
pour répondre à ces demandes
grandissantes
en fait c'est qu'il ya plusieurs raisons
pour lesquelles un enfant ne déjeunent
pas donc et c'est pas nécessairement
toujours une situation socio-économique
et les longs trajets d'autobus on est en
région ici les élèves vont probablement
faire un bon temps en autobus donc une
routine familiale chargée un manque
d'aliments sains ou de variété
d'aliments
cette réalité oblige les écoles à
s'inscrire à différents programmes pour
nourrir les élèves qui sinon comment
serait la classe le ventre vide
un cadeau des jaunisses relever que
d'une des sureaux gère les achats et les
inventaires du club des petits déjeuners
on a plus de 3300 programme à travers le
pays en collaboration avec des
organismes communautaires des milieux
scolaires on est dans plus de 60
communautés autochtones au québec et
pour nous c'est essentiel
d'y être et donc c'est plus de 500000
enfin par gens qui déjà
malgré cela plus de 630 écoles se
trouvent sur la liste d'attentes pour
l'ouverture de programmes que depuis des
années ça a commencé ici
beaucoup de dvd famille déménage
[Musique]
le style aurait et nutritionniste et
chargée de projet à l'association
québécoise de la garde scolaire et
connaît bien les enjeux des écoles
primaires elle chapeaute plusieurs
programmes dont et collations dépendant
des régions est rarement beaucoup
d'action qui est fait
pour tenter d'aider les familles qui
sont en milieu défavorisé ça peut être
le club des petits déjeuners
ça peut être un comptoir de salades
repas sur l'heure du dîner des
collations un programme également des
activités culinaires
au québec pour l'année scolaire 2009 1
2021 705 écoles primaires et 199 écoles
secondaires sont considérés défavorisés
soit 30% du réseau public au club des
petits déjeuners et à et collations
sèche doute d'autres programmes
municipaux provinciaux et nationaux des
organismes communautaires de quartier la
distribution de berlingots de lait pour
s'assurer que nos enfants ne commence
pas leur journée d'école le ventre vide
la participation financière des parents
est appuyée par des dons du secteur
privé et par de nombreuses subventions
des différents paliers de gouvernement
juste au québec le gouvernement verse
annuellement 40 5 millions $ en
subventions la ville de toronto vient
d'ajouter 16 millions à son programme de
nutrition scolaire et le gouvernement du
canada promet un milliard sur cinq ans
pour répondre à la demande
malheureusement souvent les enfants les
plus défavorisés
ne sont pour toujours rejoint par ces
mesures là je ne sais pas ce qui peut
être possible de faire mais idéalement
que les enfants milieux défavorisés
puissent avoir accès à de l'encadrement
sur l'heure du dîner de façon gratuite
pour qu'ils pussent avoir accès à ces
éléments
on est à ville saint-laurent à montréal
dans une école primaire thibault line et
pourquoi vous avez donné rendez vous
dans cette école l'école et loire
laurent participer le programme la carte
sim pour tous les besoins sont aussi
grand pour les dîners de nouvelles
initiatives voient le jour pour aider
les familles qui faute de temps ou
d'argent peine à fournir un lunch à
leurs enfants
j'aime en beauté
ce qu'on brade sa musique typiques sont
inquiets comme on est connue
la cantine pour tous et le plus récente
organisme mis en place dans 26 écoles du
québec pour permettre à tous les parents
de payer ce qu'ils peuvent pour un repas
équilibré le midi on reçoit environ une
centaine de repas du traiteur sur 300
d'auxerre 3 alors en général mais depuis
l'arrivée de la cantine pour tous on a
triplé en nombre de repas traiteur
c'était un entraînement j'ai
fait des pâtes à quoi
[Musique]
moi je mange
et on peut estimer qu'il ya peu près 16
% des enfants qui pourraient se trouver
dans une situation d'insécurité
alimentaire c'est à dire que dont les
familles pourraient vivre la difficulté
du stress pour pouvoir nourrir leurs
enfants on va éviter toute forme de
stigmatisation
on veut pas que les enfants qui
reçoivent un repas puissent être
identifiés comme des enfants issus de
familles défavorisées comme c'est le cas
dans beaucoup de programmes c'est une
méthode qui existe au canada pour le
dîner ça se fait à terre-neuve c'est là
qu'on a trouvé l'inspiration pour
d'autres modèles à nous et ça se fait
maintenant sur l'île du prince édouard
la cantine pour tous et un réseau il ya
des organismes sont des organismes
communautaires des organismes de
sécurité alimentaire qui sont dans les
quartiers qui travaille déjà avec les
écoles et qui ont une expertise en
production de repas on a une ambition
qui n'est pas juste sécurité alimentaire
à la cantine pour tous monsieur de saine
alimentation
les enfants ne mangent pas assez de
fruits et légumes dans les écoles du
québec on veut les nourrir certes
mauvais aussi qu'ils sachent se nourrir
bonjour tout le monde
oh ce que c'est bon ce que vous mangez
temps plein de bons légumes aussi
haut ce que tu as tout manger ça et
pas encore déballés tes légumes parce
que tu vas aller manger
pourquoi j'essaye tout petit peu de ce
que je ne passe notre ambition nous ce
serait qui est un programme comme
celui-là qui permettent aux enfants
d'avoir à lunch abordables dans toutes
les écoles du québec comme ça se fait
dans la plupart des pays développés dans
le monde six au brésil c'est gratuit
pour tout le monde c'est au chili c'est
gratuit pour tout le monde si ça existe
en italie au danemark c'est existe au
japon en corée et québec et au canada
sont capables de faire
alors pourquoi on n'y arrive pas malgré
toutes les ressources et les sommes
investies le problème c'est que ce ne
sont pas des programmes qui sont arrimés
1 avec l'orgue il ya pas de concertation
il ya certaines écoles qui peut avoir
trois ou quatre mêmes programmes d aide
alimentaire dans la même école ils
peuvent peut-être avoir une orange le
matin une aura aujourd'hui sans le midi
puis une orange en collation non l'après
midi et je pourrais dire que il ya
vraiment pas d'arrimage qui est fier que
l'on ya quelque part un gaspillage de
ressources
il y avait vraiment moyen d'être plus
efficace
je suis très heureux aujourd'hui de vous
annoncer le lancement d'une coalition
pour l'alimentation scolaire notre
objectif est de fournir à tous nos
enfants d'ici 2030 les repas dont ils
ont besoin pour bien apprendre et bien
gravir aller en décembre dernier les
nations unies ont créé la coalition
mondiale pour les repas scolaires qui
rassemble une cinquantaine de pays quand
je dis tiens un momentum c'est pas juste
au niveau du québec ou du canada nous on
sent ces quelque chose à l'échelle
internationale ça vous étonne que le
canada ait pas encore réagi lancer sa
participation on est très étonné on
comprend pas vraiment pourquoi
effectivement le canada ne fait pas
partie de ces 50 pays le gouvernement
fédéral nous a répondu par écrit qu'il
étudiait la possibilité de se joindre à
cette coalition et que l'expérience
d'autres pays aiderait à l'élaboration
d'une politique canadienne sur
l'alimentation en milieu scolaire on est
quand même le seul pays du g7 qui
n'avons pas de programme un programme
universel d'alimentation donc ya pas de
filet de sécurité pour que les enfants
puissent avoir accès à au moins un voire
plus repassant tous les jours lenval
tous les enfants dans son bilan de 2010
est sur le bien-être des enfants
l'unicef classé le canada au 25e rang
sur 41 pays en matière de sécurité
alimentaire pour les enfants on n'a pas
l'habitude au canada d'être aussi mal
classé en général le canada est bien
classée dans les politiques sociales et
politiques économiques etc c'est un
retard qui est assez conséquent
le gouvernement libéral s'est pourtant
engagée en 2019 a créé une politique
alimentaire universel un engagement
réitéré où l'on met de la réélection de
justin trudeau l'automne dernier une
politique très attendu par les
organismes à travers le pays avec un
programme d'alimentation universel il y
aurait une structure mieux organisés
avec plus de ressources qui travaille
pour ça à avoir une meilleure
distribution alimentaire on en connaît
beaucoup les implications des bénéfices
sur la santé et sur la réussite scolaire
avoir quelque chose qui concertée
nationalement et ça permettrait que
c'est pas chaque organisme qui décide ou
non de le faire et l'ensemble des tables
permettrait justement de vraiment bien
saisir l'ensemble de l'aide qui est
donnée de partout avez vous une oreille
attentive auprès du gouvernement du
québec oui les l'instant l'éducation
s'est montré ouvert
oui parce que yo mis en place la mesure
15 euros 12 qui visait à rejoindre
l'ensemble des écoles pas juste les
écoles de milieux défavorisés c'est une
aide supplémentaire de 11 millions de
dollars du gouvernement du québec que
beaucoup augmenté son budget dans le
domaine au cours des dernières années
comme nous le dit le ministre jean
françois roberge on a fait un effort
extrêmement important depuis de ta vie
ouvernement ont augmenté de plus de 75%
les fonds pour permettre de nourrir nos
jeunes qui autrement auraient les
difficultés à prendre parce qu'il serait
le ventre vide c'est vraiment un bon pas
dans la bonne direction
mais il manque encore de concertation
une concertation pourrait permettre que
toutes ces sommes investis soit utilisé
à bon escient pour éviter des
aberrations comme l'achat de ces
collations sucrées suremballés acheter à
partir des nouvelles subventions et
dénoncer l'automne dernier par un père
de famille quand ce qui peut arriver
quelque chose comme ça parce que les
écoles ont peu de ressources pour
mettant en place un bon système
d'approvisionnement et aussi pour
préparer les décorations sur place sont
organisés pour ça je pense qu'on est
quand même à la marge je pense pas
qu'une majorité de collations sont des
collations qu'on veut dire trop sucré
trop salé ça arrive parfois que coûte et
pour aller dans la facilité des
organisations ou des écoles qui sont
malheureuses
bartali mécanisée on dit transformer ou
sur transformé il y en a quelques uns
qui sont acceptées des aliments
transformés dans la police et carole
mais c'est pas nécessairement à ce qui
est souhaitable en collation donc on
veut vraiment des fruits des légumes les
produits laitiers on a fait beaucoup de
terrain l'émission l'épicerie personne
ne se plaint des montants attribués au
contraire tout le monde salue les
enveloppes budgétaires qui sont en place
mais on trouve difficile de coordonner
tous ces programmes là mais je vous
dirais que là on est rendu à une
meilleure concertation collaboration
pour un certain d'y voir plus clair on a
fait un grand pas mais on est encore
les intervenants sur le terrain sont
tous unanimes il faut une politique pour
unifier tout cela ce qu'on souhaite à la
cantine pour tous se tient pour à
l'universel d'alimentation scolaire
c'est ça qu'on veut ce que vous appelez
une politique uniforme en réalité ça
veut dire de former de que ce soit le
gouvernement qui donne tout les
collations et tous les repas à tous les
élèves je voudrais qu'à ce moment on
n'est pas la priorité qu'on sait donner
c'est de donner les collations dérape
aux élèves qui en ont besoin on discute
avec le gouvernement fédéral qui
pourrait être un partenaire important
pour ajouter même davantage de ça ou
pour peut-être encore plus faire le
virage vous irez vers la consommation
locale la chaude production le moins
transformé le gouvernement fédéral nous
confirment qu'il travaille à
l'élaboration de tels programmes
nationale et que c'est une priorité sans
toutefois préciser un échéancier pour sa
mise en place donc tout ça ça se
coordonnent en ce moment ce qu'est ce
qui n'était pas le cas avant donc un
momentum on en est loin on en a jamais
été aussi proche